[Music]
I'm strong I got this
Shannen Doherty is staying positive
after one of her tumor marker tests came
back elevated she took to Instagram to
share her help update writing even after
that call I'm staying positive and
taking stock of my life it certainly
helps put things in perspective and
reminds you of what you learned through
the cancer journey she added the
elevation can be from all sorts of
things and ended the post with hash tag
is still a cancer Slayer cancer is a
strange way than some amazing things for
me it's made me I think it's allowed me
to be more me like much more in touch
with who I am and much more vulnerable
and and the person that I always was but
I think I got hidden behind a lot of
other stuff Shanna was diagnosed with
breast cancer in 2015 and has openly
shared her journey in hopes she can help
others I hope one person and I and I
know I already have because I read I
read their posts in their comments on
Instagram and it it makes me feel so
good that I've had any kind of impact on
someone
[Music]